bob is with us in Portland Maine hey Bob
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
you doing better than I deserve what's
up well my son is at the Naval Academy
and their third year when they start
their third year all these kids are
eligible for a $30,000 loan
yeah and they did well it's one half of
one percent okay I know it's awful it's
cheap it's cheap money but how do I talk
my son out of out of doing this loan
even he said dad they take it out of my
pay and I'm like God I don't know I keep
telling them we listen to Dave Ramsey
says daddy's debt is bad yeah well I
mean simple here's the answer they take
it out of your pay yeah I mean it's not
it's a loan it's not a gift
yeah you have to give it back doofus no
we're not doing this
that's talk to him you want to you want
to invest it you know something mad
about this why is the Naval Academy
doing this it's an absolute disservice
to these guys and these sailors I mean
my gosh cuz you know what does a
freaking 18 year old need to do with
thirty thousand bucks right you know I'm
gonna invest it and make my spread yeah
18 year olds are known for doing that
instead of going to the Bahamas with the
money yeah they're known for that give
me a break it's just stupid it's one
more government stupid thing out there
so know it you know just telling you're
gonna knock a noggin on his head it mean
no it cuz it's not a gift if it was my
kid here's what I would say it's not a
gift doofus you got to pay it back we'll
take you down on my check yeah precisely
why don't you keep your jack yeah you
know well I'm gonna invest it to make
money no you're not you don't know what
the flip you're doing you're 18
yeah you ain't got the sense God gave a
cabbage yet okay so no we're not doing
this no neither no he's Nothe brightest
well I mean yeah they are I was bright I
knew everything when I was 18 I was an
investment expert when I was 18 but you
know the problem is it's not gonna work
wait fast-forward this to 30 years old
where's this gonna be you know I failed
a failed investment he's got $30,000 in
debt
right right no no no no okay
Naval Academy ought to have their ears
boxed for this crap they've been doing
this for years I get this call about
every three months or so and I saw awful
awful horrible how we're doing on my
favorites only a half a percent why are
you doing a favor you got $30,000 in a
debt I want to bless you I'm gonna put
you in that give me a break
it's not a blessing as people think
think think think think and they're
doing it with kids that I mean how we
work with the military all time we love
the military but sometimes they do some
of the dumb but things that just break
your heart you know and you leave the
base you leave the average military base
is not the military's fault but you
leave the base you know you drive and
for the next two miles after you pull
out of the base there's every stupid
possible human thing that can be done on
both sides of the road they set these
kids up man and you got it you got to
really put your arm around young
military folk to keep them from messing
up and much less to give them a chance
to screw up this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than
same room the channel tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you